one two three four and five I caught a
hair alive
six seven eight nine and ten I let him
go again
these numbers are everywhere in our
lives so much so that I bet you haven't
thought much about them where did they
come from where will they go
when did you get here Cotton Eye Joe
right okay so you're probably told that
these numbers are called Arabic numerals
as opposed to the Roman numerals you
also learned in school so that you can
read old clocks and tell which Super
Bowl it is I guess well what you may not
know is that the numerals aren't
actually Arabic or not Arabic originally
anyway to chart the history of these
numbers will have to go a little further
east to India
[Music]
this video is brought to you by my
patreon so most of y'all probably
already know what patreon is a platform
where audiences can financially support
their favorite creators online making
money online and having a sustainable
income from online content creation can
be hard so patreon allows creators Like
Yours Truly to receive direct support
from their viewers like you I've been
making educational videos on YouTube for
over two years now you see I graduated
from University in 2020 and as I'm sure
you remember that wasn't a very fun time
so I started making YouTube videos to
fill my time and keep me from going
crazy and the growth and positive
response to my channel has been really
overwhelming you may have seen me
already mention my patreon in my last
few videos and I already have two
patrons Brian and Peter I just want to
take a second to shout them out
specifically as my first patrons it
means a lot so there are three tiers on
the page Baron Earl and Duke each with
different perks available so if you want
to support me or if you want some of the
perks that come with the page you can
click the link in the description or go
to the address you see on screen right
now and if you are unable or unwilling
that's totally fine the best support I
receive from you is subscribing liking
commenting and just watching my videos
now back to our regularly scheduled
programming thanks a lot
our story starts in the 4th Century in
India during the Gupta Empire
this was the beginning of the golden age
of India a period of History where
considerable advancements in mathematics
science and philosophy occurred on the
Indian subcontinent things like the
decimal system and the concept of zero
were invented but before those things
could happen they needed to invent the
Hindu number system
now the symbols themselves are older
derived from the brahmi numerals from
the 3rd Century BC we aren't starting
with them because while the symbols may
be similar the underlying system is not
you see the brahmi script as well as
most numerical systems of the time like
the Chinese and Roman numerals did not
use a place value notation the
brahminumerals had separate symbols for
10 20 30 and so on this made doing
arithmetic difficult if you look to
these barami numerals we can already
recognize a couple numbers six and seven
being the most prominent
and this is how they morphed into the
Hindu numerals you can see them here on
the value or inscription
some of the numbers look more familiar
While others don't like R6 and 7 here oh
and here's a DOT for zero
so here it is the number system that
gave us our modern numbers so far the
story's been pretty straightforward some
people in India invented some numbers
and some real ingenious people created
an ingenious system oh right I haven't
explained what makes these numbers so
special well they use a decimal
positional system what does that mean
well think of this there are a total of
10 symbols in the whole of the Hindu
Arabic set one two three four five six
seven eight nine and zero with these 10
symbols we can make any number we want
simply by changing their positions and
using 0 as a TENS marker this is one at
a zero we have ten at another we have a
hundred and so on
to demonstrate the usefulness of this
here's the number 38 in Arabic numerals
and here it is in Roman numerals the
Arabic numerals only took two symbols
while the Roman numbers took seven
right so that's all fine and good but
how did these numbers get from here all
the way over to here well the clues in
the name
the first citing or mentioning of the
Indian number system in the Arab world
was before the Arab world was well the
Arab world in 662 when the Islamic
empire had just started to stretch
beyond the Arabian Peninsula a Syrian
Christian Bishop named Severus sabok
wrote about the Hindu numbers and the
genius of the Indian mathematicians
quote I will omit all discussion of the
science of the Indians of their subtle
discoveries in astronomy discoveries
that are more ingenious than those of
the Greeks and the Babylonians and of
their valuable method of calculation
which surpassed description I wish only
to say that this computation is done by
means of nine signs if those who believe
because they speak Greek that they have
arrived at the limits of science would
read the Indian texts they would be
convinced even if a little late in the
day that there are others who know
something of value
this quote is brilliant not only does it
diss the Hellenistic people for their
cultural chauvinism but it also
communicates the awareness and respect
some in the Middle East had towards
Indian scientists
the Hindu numerals pop up again about a
hundred or so years later in the
writings of al-qaerismi unfortunately we
don't have a copy of the book he wrote
discussing the numbers we instead have a
Latin translation that was changed when
translated we then have writings on
Indian arithmetic by Al uglyitis and
principles of Hindu Reckoning by kushar
IBN Laban both written in the 10th
century
these three Works show that by this time
Islamic mathematicians and astronomers
were using the Hindu numerals
extensively though most common Arabs
even literate ones were not this makes
sense as for simple monetary or business
transactions one only need basic
arithmetic and most people would do that
using their fingers
so we now have the numerals in the Arab
world but at this point the symbols were
starting to disperse into three
different varieties in India they had
shifted to the Sanskrit divinagari still
used today in India in Arabia Syria and
Egypt they turned to what we call the
East Arabic numerals still used in parts
of the Middle East and lastly the West
Arabic numerals sometimes called the
gubar numerals evolved in North Africa
it is these gubar numbers that will lay
the foundation for our modern symbols
the Western numerals made their way into
Europe through Spain where the oldest
example of their use is in the Codex
vigilantis written by monks in
976. some in Europe liked the system
like Pope Sylvester II who tried to
spread it around Italy to no avail as
most medieval Europeans used Roman
numerals the great mathematician
Fibonacci used them in his
groundbreaking Liber abachi in 1202 and
from there the system eventually spread
it was around the 15th century that the
numbers finally cut on in Europe and
here's an example from Albert Durer in
1514 showing the numbers in their
current form so there we are the history
of the Hindu Arabic numerals from India
to Arabia to Spain to Italy and
eventually the world if you want to
support the Channel please consider
donating to my patreon and don't forget
to like And subscribe
bye
[Music]